6:30 ранку. Нана Гурабанідзе виходить із дому
з відром гарячої води прямо з-під крану.
Корові треба помити вим’я перед тим, як почати доїти.
Трохи згодом вона починає робити сир.
Тут потрібне терпіння.
Сир виходить добрим, лише коли все строго за технологією.
Протягом дня жінка працює як годинник,
ніколи не спиняючись на перепочинок.
- Як у домогосподині в мене багато роботи.
Прибираю, готую їжу, дою корів та багато інших справ.
Робота завжди є.
Нані Гурабанідзе - за шістдесят.
30 років вона була медсестрою.
Живе з чоловікою, сином, невісткою та онуками.
- Гаряча вода зажди потрібна.
Добре, що в нас є бойлер.
Гарячу воду сім'я Нани отримала завдяки
місцевому енергетичному кооперативу.
Вода підігрівається сонячною енергією.
- Ми трохи заощадили і дещо продали.
Мій чоловік дуже таке хотів.
Це дорогувато, але підйомно.
- Він хотів полегшити вам домашню роботу?
- Думаю, радше хотів заощадити на електроенергії.
Але напевно не скажу.
Колись у нас була пічка і йому потрібно було
постійно ходити по дрова і стежити, чи вдосталь дрів ми маємо.
Сир готовий. Пані Нана понесе його на базар у Кутаїсі.
Сюди люди приносять те, що вирощують чи виготовляють удома:
овочі, фрукти, трави та сир.
Нана ледь устигає розкластися, як
приходить закупниця і забирає значну частину сиру.
Залежно від виду сиру вона платить у перерахунку
1,5 - 2,5 євро за кілограм.
- Багато цим не заробиш,
але якщо жити ощадливо, то можна вкластися.
Ми намагаємося вкладатися.
Ліза Бачілава також займається господаркою,
а крім того на ній - ферма та онуки.
Вона досі підігріває воду традиційно:
на плиті, яку розпалюють дровами.
Їй потрібно багато гарячої води,
а отже й багато дрів.
Щороку дрова обходяться її родині у 200-240 євро.
Це немало, адже в Грузії річний середній прибуток родини
- до 3,5 тисяч євро.
- Ми заощаджуємо, тому можемо собі дозволили дрова.
Але, на жаль, багатьом іншим родинам це не вдається.
У нас ситуація трохи краща.
Ми можемо заплатити за дрова, а бідні люди - ні.
Чоловіки збирають дрова високо в горах Кавказу.
Тут досі можна самовільно вирубувати ліс.
Гогіті Чікладзе 27 років,
він постійно сюди ходить по дрова.
За його оцінками, кожнісінький будинок
у цьому регіоні щороку спалює 2-3 вантажівки дрів.
- Якщо рубати ліс у якомусь іншому місці,
можна спричинити обвал, і людям у селі буде лихо.
Ця діброва може здатися густою, але
вирубка лісів стає справжньою катастрофою для Грузії.
Щоби зберегти ліси,
вирубувати потрібно у 12 разів менше.
Ці чоловіки працюють над тим, щоб вирішити проблему.
Вони виготовляють сонячні панелі.
Верстат, здається, ще з часів Другої світової,
але досі працює.
Це одне з приміщень енергетичного кооперативу.
Сонячні панелі можуть зменшити споживання дрів,
а отже й викиди парникових газів.
Кооператив уже забезпечив сонячними панелями
і бойлерами понад 100 будинків у селі.
Маріетта Летодіані - місцева вчителька
та голова енергетичного кооперативу,
назва якого перекладається як "Увімкніть сонце".
У цьому будинку саме монтують сонячні панелі.
- Місцеві мешканці знають про систему нагріву води.
Вони знають, що банк дає кредити на це.
Нам навіть не треба ходити і стукати у двері.
Ті, хто зацікавився, самі приходять до нас.
У Маріетти вдома також стоять панелі.
- Так, ми поставили ще три роки тому.
Все чудово, це заощаджує гроші та ще й
полегшує домашню роботу.
Нана Гурабанідзе повернулася додому з базару.
На той час уже прокинулися онучки.
Син та невістка на роботі, тож їй треба займатися дітьми.
На відпочинок знову немає часу.
- Мені 60 років і, думаю, моє життя майже добігає кінця.
Я зроблю все можливе, щоб дати дітям та онучкам
краще майбутнє. Сподіваюся, їхнє життя буде легшим.
Гаряча вода прямо з крану – хороший початок для цього.